brother you're driving
133 mph in a 55 mph Zone driver shut the
vehicle off and put your hands out the
[Laughter]
window driver shut the vehicle off put
your hands out the window both
hands put both your hands out the
window
give me
Keys explain it to me man I'm brushing
because I had brother you're driving
133 mph in a 55 mph zone right it was an
emergency what is the emergency I got
stuff going on my live kid I'm trying to
get I got stuff going on with my family
here's the thing you want to have
conversation that doesn't end with you
going to jail you might want to be a
little more forthcoming with the details
what is the situation that causes you to
drive 2 and 1/2 times the speed limit
down the highway to the
airp okay so you going to drive 130 plus
milph the entire way to the airport
putting everybody else's life on the
highway in Jeopardy that's what you're
telling me do me a favor how
about face that way when you get
out
get out and face that way I ain't asking
you I'm telling you get out and face
that way get out and face that
way you got anything on you I need to
know about guns drugs knives bombs is
there anything in the car I need to know
about no you're under arrest for
reckless
driving was that was brother you're
doing
133 down the highway in the HOV lane
putting everybody's life in jeopardy cuz
you want to go to to the airport come on
man my girl is pregnant bro I'm not so
what does that have to do with it I'm
running late that's sleep okay so your
poor time management is what's going to
cost other somebody else their life
that's what you're telling me have a
seat
24 get in I just talk to we we can in a
second but nothing is nothing you're
going to say he's going to change the
fact you're under arrest understand that
1024 I'm going to have one in custody uh
can you start at 85 we're going to be I
guess 75 85
Southbound at 14 like under 14th Street
on the right
shoulder all right what do you got what
do you want to talk about oh girl this
CR get to it I was running late my eyes
I have a star in my eye okay so you
can't see real
well no I can see
but my I wasn't trying to put uh 133
coming south by on the
Highway okay so what you're saying to me
is that even worse than the fact that
you're driving 133 and a 55 is you can't
see real well no that's not while you're
driving 133 mph down BR you're driving
almost 80 mph over a 55 mph speed
because you're trying to get to the
hospital or you're trying to get to the
airport I'm trying to get to the airport
what time her plane land all
her plane landed what plane already
landed
I okay okay so then she's on the ground
she's safe she can sit there but you're
you're going to cause yourself
potentially a life in prison if you kill
somebody while driving almost 80 mph
down the over the speed limit down the
highway to save yourself what 10
minutes sir but I mean that's I'm not
crazy Rel that's just crazy to drive
that
fast to to to try and save yourself 10
minutes while she I mean she's on the
ground what is what is the dire hurry to
get to her that causes you to drive that
fast just just the fact that she's
coming into town and you're running
late just trying to get straight to her
and get back to the house I just told
you well here's the thing you're under
arrest for reckless driving and a bunch
of other traffic tickets we are going to
go your car is going to get impounded
sir we're going to go down to City Jail
get booked into jail and then whenever
they let you out they let you
out what's up you got to speak up man
with all these cars I can't hear what
you're saying to me I said I didn't I
wasn't trying to harm anyone sir okay
but I just what I did was in I'm I'm I
have no reason to go to I you got a
reason for I was speeding but I'm not a
bad dude I mean I didn't listen brother
I didn't say you were a bad dude but you
just made a couple decisions that put a
lot of people's lives in Jeopardy and
you run my record like you see like I
mean I might run your record but it's
not going to change the outcome of what
like past good behavior doesn't excuse
future current poor Behavior like that
would that would be like saying well I
mean you're honor I've never done
anything wrong like can I get a pass on
killing this person cuz I've never done
anything wrong in the past
like I'm happy you don't have a jacked
up driving record I am like I'm happy
about that but
like it and then you know you're wrong I
mean you know you're wrong because as
soon as I start driving past you you
jump across five Lanes of traffic to try
and hide from me on the other side of
the highway no I was about to get off my
exit I wasn't the airport is 15 miles
that way so either so you're getting off
an exit right here then you ain't going
to the airport I got ways on my I'm not
lying to Brother come on I I literally
work traffic and drive the highway for a
living my office is down by the airport
not I mean it's not even all the way to
the airport you literally stay on the
the highway that you're on and keep on
driving for the better part of 12
miles so now we're just not being honest
with each other but you're out set hang
out for sir you before you do just can I
just make the phone call we we'll worry
about phone calls in a
minute
fa Fair be a punched I probably would
never caught him in the first
place are there any weapons in the car
no but you got to extend ended mag Glock
sitting on the fucking passenger
seat which is not
chambered but
has
rounds
unre back on
DET
keep driving South for 10
miles on your own ways says keep driving
South for 10 miles you ain't trying to
get off your exit you're trying to hide
from the
police all right since you don't have
any on you and there's none in your car
you have a driver's license
yes sir I have no driver license okay
whose car are you driving has it
reported ahead all right so what do you
think when I asked you hey do you have
any in the car I need know about guns
drugs knives bombs and you go no but you
got an extended mag Glock sitting on the
passenger seat it's in my name I was
going to tell you as you I asked you and
I said is there anything in the car I
need to know about guns rugs KN bombs
you looked at me dead in my face and
said
no okay but I didn't ask you if you
it's not a big deal you're not it's not
against the law to have a gun in your
car unless you're a convicted
felon okay are you a convicted felon
okay all right you get one chance to
tell me what your name
is I li to I mean brother you've already
lied to me about having a gun in your
car so you about a gun sir I I asked you
PL point blank to your face sir do you
have a gun in your car and you said said
you looked me in my face and said no so
what do you mean you ain't lied to me
yet what's your birthday I'm not trying
to lie to you about nothing I'm not
trying to get your back right Mr Carter
what's your birthday apiz Mr Carter
what's your
birthday
okay
perfect
that all right is the gun stolen I'm not
asking you cuz I'm trying to be mean to
you I'm asking you cuz I just it's just
easier for me if I know ahead of time
and then we can go about
that here's a thing man a also I'm
getting off for my exit for your own G
PS says tells you to drive for 9.7 more
miles on the street that you're on so
there's no way that you were jumping
over you're jumping over cuz you're
hoping that I don't find you in traffic
as I'm coming to get to you right sir I
didn't I didn't see you to the blue
lights I'm sorry you hit the brakes as
soon as you came by me on the side of
the
highway I didn't I didn't see the blue
lights on oh man I didn't turn the blue
lights on until I was right behind you
but I'm just saying I mean you saw me on
the side of the
highway
got to make some better choices here
brother I don't here's the
thing the right I I got you but you you
can't be doing the right thing by doing
a bunch of other stuff wrong like
that that's
not just ran out the house and trying to
do TR go to the a pick up my just I was
I was feeling was ring I wasn't trying I
didn't think I was going to go to jail
not trying to go to jail I mean I don't
think anybody wakes up hope like
thinking that they're going to jail man
but like it's not like you're doing 90
and a
55 like you're doing almost 80 M an hour
over the speed limit of 55
mph like if you were going 80 and a 55
like that's still 25 over that's still
SC but you're going to have you know
you're going to end up with a
ticket doing 80 mph over a 55 mph speed
limit okay we want to thank Morgan and
Morgan for sponsoring this body cam
video I mean I think it's pretty clear
from the body cams that we covered that
it's not always safe out there when
you're hurt it can be confusing it can
be scary you don't really know where to
turn well Morgan and Morgan is actually
the largest injury law firm in in
America and in a time when you already
have so much to think about they're
going to make it super easy for you they
have completely modernized the process
because you submit your claim you sign
contracts you upload documents you talk
to your whole legal Team all on your
phone that's it an attorney is going to
review your case in just eight clicks
also they have 4,000 support staff that
can help you too which is just amazing
to think about and in terms of price
well you only pay them if you win
there's no upfront fee so if you're
injured and you want to join the over 3
million people that call them every year
you can submit a claim at www.
forthepeople.com
LC bodycam or by dialing pound law
that's pound 529 on your phone 52 West
that's uh mayor what's
that
133 stop so I'm
in I'm you do 133 like that
that's that's that's Insanity
like what's
up I
have anything that you can do that I
don't have to jail there is nothing that
is going to change the outcome of we
going to jail
tonight
what okay let me let me ask you this
just so I can better understand what do
you think is a Equitable solution to the
fact that you're driving 78 mph over a
55 mph speed limit driving in the HOV
lane by yourself and then in an effort
to not get pulled over cut across five
Lanes of traffic to try and hide on the
far right lane what do you think is an
appropriate like if you were me and you
would p and you would pull me
over for for driving that that Reckless
what do you think is a real honest
outcome what's up
brother all
right I me that that's literally
everything that's going to
happen I mean you're going down there
for until you can see a judge and the
judge can figure out you getting back
out and then all the other stuff as far
as driving classes and whatever whatever
like you're still probably going to end
up having to do all that but we don't
set that that that's all the port sets
all there is nothing that is going to
change the outcome of you going to jail
tonight
yeah give me one
second city of
Atlanta no it's pre that's that's fton
County that's pre
TR
I what I did was serious
serious CH yeah man
yeah there no way
how do what do you mean how can I put
you in without going to jail
just right
L all right what's pass go to your
phone 0
what all right who you trying to call
yeah
to the Zer the the four
ones
Jail jail
jail go to
jail
take know pre you said pre- trial
pre-trial yeah pre trial it's the city
of Atlanta Gil city of Atlanta
Gil
yeah
Ramsey Mr Ramsey off ram officer
okay might be charge you got a bunch of
traffic tickets man and then assuming
that like your gun's not stolen you're
not a felon whenever I get around
checking that you say you already
checked no I haven't checked I'm just
telling you that I but it's one of those
things that like until I know that then
that's where we're
at it's bad guy I didn't say you were a
bad guy man but we have we have policies
that we have to follow I didn't
know okay apolog I I understand that
listen to man I'm not mad at you I'm
just this this is what it is when you're
driving 133 and a 55 like all
right come to the jail right now
yeah pre-trial it's this if you Google
the city of Atlanta jail it's the only
one that comes up it's like 254 Peach
Street 254 pach Street yeah
okay and it's called pre-trial no it's
the city of Atlanta jail the the
nickname when people say Rice Street
usually they know the pre-trial is the
non non R Street version Okay cool so
city of Atlanta jail
thank you yes ma'am all right bye by I
have no idea how to hang up on this
phone
call all right who you what is
it you want to call the same
number 51 11
on Robert Robert
51 go to jail like they lock you
up Robert Rober
5 have I don't know
what I just need only thing I need y'all
to do is just like
just come like
help
not you're not going to R
Street man that's see you yeah
now nothing I can do not to go to jail
jail I got F too I was not trying to Har
nobody
try what I came out do was not me I know
I got dreads I know I'm in the track I
have another car I just tried I wasn't
trying to race nobody it's nothing
Google my uh my my gun whatever you got
to do it's nothing it's nothing I'm I'm
sorry was accid I going do it again but
I don't I don't have to go jail son
jail me anything that me do everything
else
jail
my
address at no at no point how do you
know who I think you are man
like you made a bad choice it's one of
those things now you have to deal with
the outcome of a bad
choice you're going to be in jail for
like hours until you whether they they
decide whether you see a judge not Jud
and they're going to send you on their
way I I am making that call and my call
is that you go to
jail brother you driving almost 80 M an
hour over the speed limit and I
apologize okay I I get that I'm okay but
you still have eyes brother you still
have eyes you can still look down and
see oh crap I'm doing triple
digits you're doing like 95 which is 40
over I would have let you
with some tickets but that not a thing
anymore
like
1024 I'm checking it right
now 1024 can you run a check on a
firearm for
me
I don't
particularly it's a lot of paperwork for
me to do to to to take you to jail like
I don't want to be out here doing this
but at the same time like I can't in
good conscience just have you have you
driving 100 haven't you driving
13 my carop thank
you my
car take me back to to the crib bro I
don't have to I can't drive you back to
Fairburn why you have to take me
to well all I can tell you and and it's
I I don't know how to I don't know how
to put it any different way like nothing
is going to change the outcome of what's
about to
happen I mean it's not it's not like
it's just me and I'm trying to be mean
to you or anything like that like this
is I mean nobody wants to go to jail
it's not like I want to be out here to
be the one putting you in jail out going
to jail byed it's kind of hard stay out
you know what I'm saying it's kind of
hard man it's kind of hard I feel you
like I don't want to beg
you no nothing I just want to do
something get somebody up help somebody
else
d
all
damn
man
unfortunately that's where
we're hey how you
doing Dan prob got my nephew Jordan so
where's the vehicle going okay going
talk fine I apologize for the
misunderstanding uh where are you guys
taking to
City okay put that at me put that in my
GPS so I'll know what's going on should
be like 250 have you type in city of
Atlanta jail in city of Atlanta jail
okay city of
Atlanta can we just step over here from
the
highway okay city of Atlanta
jail so who is he to you my nephew neph
good kid yeah good kid man listen I I've
tried to explain to him that I have
nothing no ill will against him but he
made a real bad choice so okay he was
driving 133 and a 55 oh man and in the H
lane and then when I tried to like get
close to pull him over he just ducked
across five Lanes of traffic to try and
hi from me I'm out here asking him like
hey man you got any like guns drugs now
he's like no no I'm good but he's got an
extended M Glock sitting in the
passenger seat like okay he's I don't
think he's just thinking with his clear
head okay all right ain't nothing crazy
he's not going for you know for felonies
or nothing but like AB we can't be out
here driving 78 M hour over the speed
limit putting everybody else's life in
jeopardy so you have to he got to sit
down for a minute and yeah I mean
realistically I don't we don't set
whether they have to see judges not have
to see judges the corrections do that
okay so if he does have to see a judge
that should be it like 10 or 12 tomorrow
morning okay and then you know they'll
they'll figure out can he just bond out
sign out does he have to like I don't
know we have no control over that
process so so what what actually so you
said he was he was driving 133 and a 55
in the H Lane 133 and the 55 in the HOV
lane so once he see once you put the
light
well no before I got close enough to him
to put the lights on he just jumped from
the h Lane all the way to the far right
lane which again like other than being
an unsafe Lane change like I I mean that
is what it is you know you're just
trying to not get pulled over exactly
exactly toally understand he's not the
first he won't be the last he probably
won't be the last tonight but it's one
of those things like he's doing 90 and a
55 all right man here here's a speed and
ticket you be on your way right 133 and
a 55 like you were putting so so many
other people's lives in danger like
that's just not something that I can
give you a
ticket
Cooperative okay I got no ill will for
him or for what so you saying by him
doing 130 right I can't just give you a
ticket and then be like okay hey man
listen I know you've been reckless
driving you have to get arrested okay
it's one of those things like it's your
discretion reckless driving is thing
okay if you're getting exited for
reckless D now yes is there discretion
for some stuff of course there no
argument there but you just cannot be
out here
driving so like I said we're going to go
down to City of Atlanta Jan okay they'll
square away whether he can just sign out
tonight bond out tonight or whether he
has to see a judge yeah we don't have b
m tonight right and then if they you
know once they determine that but we
won't know that like I won't even know
that right cuz you guys have we got to
get down there and then they got they
process him abely so once that process
starts for him yeah he'll be able to
contact y'all let you guys know what you
know hey you guys can get me out tonight
hey I can't get out till tomorrow okay
um and be able to call you guys can I
get your C I don't have C you have a um
I'm going to get the uh tow truck
information so if he's good with it a
couple things are going to happen here
one I'm going to give you the impound
slip for the car which so his car is
going to hoo so that's address phone
number for them I'm going to give this
to you cuz it doesn't really serve him
any benefit to have it you have it and
then if he is uh good with it I will
give you his firearm um cuz I ran his
firearm it's not stolen so we're that
absolutely uh the only thing is that do
you have a carry permit no not on me
right now okay so I will put it in your
car but we're going to put it in the
trunk okay that's um just for
everybody's ease and then you guys can
get it back to him as opposed to him
having to go up get it out of property
and and do all that that czy I just got
to ask him and make sure that it's okay
with him that you take possession of it
absolutely you have ID on it yes sir not
sure I
absolutely if he says yes to that I just
have to list you in his report yes for
nothing other than you took possession
of his property at his request well I'm
going to have my wife take care of that
as the CU that's is M that's is she here
yes she's absolutely here give me one
second okay so give my ID give me one
second yeah I just need somebody's ID
for who's going to take his
St do you know the
gentleman who's
that Uncle all right do you want your
uncle or his wife or some combination of
that to take possession of your firearm
so that you do not have to go get it out
of property or do you want to get put in
property take it you want them to take
it okay would you like them to take your
actually you know what I'm going to let
you keep your phone
cuz they're going to let you get numbers
out of it down to the jail so you can
call people so it's better if your phone
stays with them but the gun otherwise
you would have to go get your gun back
out of property once you get out so um
if you good
with this nice lady taking that from for
you we can do that
yes taking me to jail you are 100% going
to jail there's there's nothing that's
changed in that fact the question is do
you want them to take possession of your
firearm yeah yeah of course okay sir I
just need your driver's license
man so
far I give you all credit I don't know
how you get anything done with those
Nails I know i' I'd break every single
one of them the day I got them exactly
all right Miss Brown I'm my sir I'm back
my you're fine all right so you're going
to at his request I'm going to put this
in the trunk of y'all's car yes sir um
you guys are going to take possession of
it again his request you're going to get
listed in his report his arrest report
just as mentioned in the you know the
narrative description of what happened
by name and date of birth in case they
have questions just stating that you
took possession of this for him at his
request okay just so it's one of those
like we just have to list somebody so
that tomorrow nobody can be like well
officer Ramsey stole my property and I'm
like no I didn't like I gave it to
correct Miss Brown at your request so
whenever he backs up I'll just toss this
in the trunk you can have a seat if you
want I'm just going to I just have to
write your stuff down real quick and
I'll get it back to you okay now where
is is he going to be taken to he's going
to Whoa stop man don't got be that close
can you pop your trunk
okay so he's going to get taken to the
city of Atlanta jail okay so like 3
miles that way okay um we don't have
any involvement in the like booking
process so I don't know whether he can
get booked out tonight bonded out or
whether he has to see a judge or how any
of that stuff works um he won't know
that or I'm I probably won't never know
he won't know that until he gets down
there so his phone is still I still have
his phone can we take his phone so the
only reason I want to say no to that is
they will let him get numbers out of his
phone at the jail and then keep his
phone at the jail with him so when they
release him he will have his phone okay
to contact you guys if you guys take his
phone and he doesn't know numbers off
the top of his head or he just can't
like can't get it there's no way he can
get it okay it's one like his phone is
not going to get put in property when
they let him out they're going to hand
his phone back okay but if I take his
like his gun or other stuff that he
might have had which he didn't have
anything then it's got to go to property
he's got to go somewhere totally
different off Bank Head Highway to go
get it once he's out which is why if you
guys were good with it okay yeah like
you know he caused no problems this is
just one of those things like you just
there's some stuff that just can't Absol
can't slide like 133 and a 55 like he oh
he was driving real fast okay
so I will just get your stuff written
down real quick and then you guys are
did you get the tow TR to paper that's
my fault hang on one
second up can you can pass me quick yeah
give me one second just let me finish up
want come back here talk
to okay
so you don't know if they're going to
book him or not so so they're going to
they they're going to have to book him
okay all right so AO address and phone
number is where his car is going to be
okay okay they're going they they have
to book it the what I was saying is that
we the Atlanta Police Department have no
control over his booking process okay so
I don't know are they going to let him
just sign himself back out and he's out
in 2 hours does he have to get bonded
out does he have to see a judge does he
not have to see a judge that's not
something that we have any control over
or we decide that's correction we know
once they do it right so he will he will
know was it 11:00 yeah realistically
let's say by midnight would be my hope
okay we should be down there I should be
able to get down there you know he's got
some tickets I got to write out we'll
get those print out I would hope let's
say 12:30 okay to
be generous on the time um he should be
a to call you guys and say Hey listen
yes I can get bailed out hey I can sign
myself out can somebody come pick me up
or hey I got to see a judge this is what
time tomorrow I'm going to see a judge
and then they'll let you know cuz the
judges if he has to get like the bond
set that has to get set by the court but
we don't set bond amounts just like we
don't set appearance in before judges
that's all Corrections in the court okay
okay now if he can tonight is it okay
that we hang around the area if he is
able to get bonded out tonight and we
pay it is that okay I'm yeah I mean like
I have no control I mean I wouldn't
there's really no like jail parking lot
okay cuz it's right on the the corner of
like P Tre Memorial okay so there's not
I can stay in the vicinity right yeah I
mean you have to could go and and sit
somewhere nearby or whatever he just has
to get processed so that he can contact
y'all and tell you what the story that
he's ready to be picked up right either
he's ready to be picked up or he's got
to see a judge or whatever it is okay so
you can write my wife's information out
you get him we get this process right so
as soon as I can get her stuff down
y'all are good to go we'll go and the
faster I can get him in hopefully the
FAS y we can follow you there right yeah
we can if we I mean you can just when I
pull into the when I pull off Petri
Street into the jail don't pull into
that bark but give me one second to get
your license back
and oh he wants to talk to
you
get
out you got water I do not but we're uh
we'll get down there get
some 10 Drive Street
Optima attack Tom Ed John
check I
got all right there's your driver's
license
we're going to like I said we're going
to head down we're going to get off um
MLK and then kind of go down to Pudo
side street get on Memorial Memorial to
Peach Tree and then I'm going to turn to
Peach Tre it's basically it's right
across from the big Mar station okay is
is where we're going to be on on the
bottom end of beach okay all right okay
thank you yes
ma'am
[Applause]
24 can you show me transporting one M
from my location to City Jail starting
mileage
keep
yeah
why are we driving 35
miles
not
fantastic
oh
Daya
say PR
pre so when when you ask Rice Street
Rice Street is felonies and
stuff pre-trials like traffic tickets
and DUIs and city ordinance charges
and stuff like
that LE less serious is the
answer so
uh
I slwe the Atlanta Police Department
have no control over your booking
process I don't I don't know man I'd
literally just be making up an answer if
I told you something so the people that
are going to be able to answer that
question for you
are
the ladies and gentlemen at
Corrections which we'll be at in about 2
minutes now we just got I got to fill
out your your tickets and then go inside
once they start booking you they'll be
able to give you an exact answer of your
timeline as far as getting out whether
you can get out tonight whether you can
get out tomorrow like all that stuff is
is out of my knowledge or
control
i p
through
yeah Grand my Rec see I was
still I don't know how to explain this
any
different
SEC thank you
ma'am
I I got you again I'm
not I'm not mad at you I'm not and if
you had
been argumentative compatitive like I
wouldn't have even asked the question
about given you know giving your license
to family or giving your
giving your gun to family and stuff like
I would
just yeah we're we're going to go inside
one second and you're going to be able
to sit down and grab some water and if
you want to take that off put in your
pocket it's totally fun just give me one
second make
sure
yeah don't have a what I'll call a
pristine driving record but it ain't
that
[Music]
bad all right we're going to go inside
sit down while I do the rest your
paperwork and get get some water
and you com
come
just going to go that door to the
left you still here I didn't know you
were still here does it work yeah did
you need to copy
that it's last test out of
drun
it was uh His official is higher than
that when we went to Tech slightly lower
than that but higher than that all right
but we it's was it toner huh was it
toner or something else yeah I think
something was wrong with the Drone the
toner fine okay but it works now yeah
fair
enough
come
on Mr Carter I'm ask your question don't
get offended I ask everybody the same
question if I take your handcuffs off
are you going to do something stupid
fantastic stand up so I can get those
cuffs off the water fountains right
there once we get you use bathroom or
anything I know that's I'm
trying I
got much more got couple minutes
be
where
do you want
water it's best best I can do for
you
once we go once we're done we go back
into that room the nurse is going to
come out and ask you a bunch of
questions take a temperature about like
covid and monkey pox and whether you
want to hurt or kill yourself or other
people or whatever uh I mean answer how
you want my recommendation is no
because they don't take jokes well but
if you say something kind of crazy
they're gonna have me take you to
cating which is just going to add about
10 or 12 hours to this
process and then we'll come right back
here
in
sh
[Music]
oh got got
sneeze
radio 72 by 20 West at Capital Toyota
Avalon white and color Georgia tag Tom
Edward
12 go ahead
129 R do you have a murderer unit or
general investigator
working investigator un
investigator GI does not come on until
midnight cop Burg answer
why are you getting
[Music]
all
23 right now
hold that stuff get squared away so you
can get
out3 show
me this car go standing against the wall
over
good how are
[Music]
you what's his
off I don't know this this guy
like
weird you put me next my favorite Rapp
in the
world that is
crazy
fuck God got
[Music]
real but
yeah here we'll be
yeah this is not how I want to
[Applause]
[Music]
my
watching pain
[Music]
TR I know I know sheeld it pretty well
too that's all
count that count might be 11 yeah
I just
here I'm people work here after 11 and
something
yeah stand here make me stand
here you
see start coming like oh my
God
I
what bar you fix
perform just
tell
H3 call
I it should be reset now I
apologize ask
[Music]
they
you all
done you guys done theight
hours what about you
s we are just getting started
yeah
yeah slowing down the rest of the
evening hours to go it's got to be dead
like 4 to I mean we don't we're usually
done done like working working by 2 or
three other than people call on us to
say
hey this 41 years person
drunk but even that we don't usually go
out after like 4:45 5:00 I like it
unless it's something something crazy
yeah we had to go out once like
6:30 last summer but it was like one of
the majors was driving down street and
got sided by a drone we like we like
yeah we hey we they like yeah become
available
Yeah by become available I be here now
okay you don't have a choice N
I like who was involved they like unit
15 okay yeah yeah run
run
coming
62 for the year
so we always aage trying to get it to 10
in a
month some months goes over some months
goes under yeah like I'm at two for
September but this is going to be the
first full work week that I've had in
September CU I was on vacation for a
while yeah but I'm trying to get to 100
by the end of the
year they'll go pretty quick after a
while it's the same as like you talk to
like y talk to Apex guys you drugs or
stole whatever like they're like we can
crank this thing out in an hour like if
I sit down and apply myself I could
realistically get mine done under an
hour yeah but that's anybody injured at
alls a couple hundred of anybody feel
like they want to hurt or kill anybody
been in a car accident
[Music]
tonight
not a bad thing it's not a good thing
you want to
M Ian I understand why I'm just saying
it's
[Music]
nonsense nope
kind a court City
[Music]
Hall she man what you going to use the
whole bottle huh so what you going to
use the whole bottle yeah I'm not
trying not
trying that's
[Music]
fair
said
[Music]
what's your
name I can't hear you
[Music]
Carter all
right
you know where did this they just got to
watch me do
it what's
up you ain't got no
slides on go you come back walk put back
on that's apparently is's
husband
what
yeah after he started talking I was like
all right well let me go look but yeah I
got was tripping
out that's my
man I well no okay so I guess until 202
was still still
okay
55 what's he driving
track
drinking just one of those things
like you hit over a buck 30 like we're
going to take a ride I can't I can't in
good conscience just hand you some
tickets and be like all right man drive
yeah go ahead be on your
way